I worry a lot a lot of fear in in taking
some of the projects I take just really
uh yeah well I'm doing this VMAs in two
weeks right I'm oh yeah I heard about
that and honestly my first thought was
like what the [ __ ] is that's crazy
well it's it's it's a challenge for me
because a it's not my audience I mean
see skews younger yeah my audience is
typically you know thirty to sixty
sambro jag also cufflinks I know it's
getting hot bro man you have a huge huge
audience that gets good entertainment so
that's who you have yeah so you're
worried that well I mean it's its first
of all I mean you you all know as a
comedian when you do comedy at a musical
event yeah that you know sometimes it
could be difficult to connect with the
crowd just because you know they're
listening to music and then you come on
and you have to kind of segue and do a
joke here there so it's not listing it
right yeah it's um hosting us i'm now
you never saw the you never would have
thought that you'd be hosting the vmn
knows it wasn't on my vision board like
you write [ __ ] down I do have a vision
board actually and I want a black son
when they have two black kids on my
vision board you know two black kids
yeah okay so people always I don't tell
people that often because they don't see
it the way I see it you know how do you
see it I see it as these are gonna be my
son these gonna be my sons one day I
think other people see like Oh a guy
from the southeast a couple of black
guys on a vision board you know I think
they kind of get a you know they're
looking at it different so if I go into
your house and looked at the vision
board you got two two black kids up
there yeah they're happy as a school
book under his arm
it wasn't my sons man okay and no matter
who my sons are or what you know what
cause you know what tent they come in
they're gonna be you know hopefully
they're gonna be reading decently and
doing good stuff you know but dude
that's crazy you're gonna be hosting the
VMAs you have to be a little nervous huh
I'm a lot nervous I wouldn't be living
if I'm not really feeling this stuff so
you know the music skewing younger never
hosted anything before well you know
like you know you got to write the
company for the night you know and my
comedy generally is tested at the Comedy
Store and whatnot so the monologue that
I'm opening up with you know I've been
working on but haven't really tested it
in front of a live audience which I will
you know moving forward this week and
next but yeah it's it's it's a daunting
task but are you gonna talk about
celebrities and stuff you have to kind
of I mean MTV's turn if this was rob
dyrdek
24 hours a day I think I feel like it's
just that show ridiculousness yeah
there's a lot of that but I'm not my
Styles not ripping people to shreds my
Styles a little bit more I'm gonna
tailor the comedy to what I what I do on
stage and kind of fit it into the
environment rather than go on stage and
go well Drake's here tonight yeah I
don't know it's not really what I do
what I do so right oh wow that's cool
though cuz that that's I think when I
heard about it I was like oh man it's
abassin gonna do that it's just
different it's just different than him
that would just to me it would seem so
scary you know
it's frightening but it's good it's a
good frightening you know like I believe
that if you don't challenge yourself in
this business and we've taught the
offline about this like you know getting
a little maybe your momentum is not
there or your passion is not there maybe
in certain different things I feel that
you know the challenge is where you kind
of get the passion back and or putting
yourself in situations that you
typically wouldn't put yourself in to
you know overcome and succeed so you
know doing that yeah doing one this is
definitely one of those that's wild
so yeah it's been good don't worry you
know where did how like I am the outfits
are next next next week I'm not gonna
come out there and a see-through leopard
nipple shirt how many gross of sequins
are in the mail right now
it's a Los Angeles to Acosta there might
be a sequined jacket or two looking like
a six year old Italian he's trying to
[ __ ] get one last run at some [ __ ]
over though no I want to real I want you
to come out this in row there's gonna be
a lot of yeah I think I'm the prop maybe
one of the oldest hosts I've ever had at
least the may be the only host they've
ever had would gray hair definitely so
you might wanna know who's being honest
about their age as well 46 years old
doing doing the uh the VMAs so yeah
that's that's gonna be exciting
who are you uh who's somebody that you
are kind of low-key excited about seeing
at the VMAs like just to see do you
already know everybody's gonna be there
and stuff yes they've given me a list
Who am I excited to see this is this is
why they picked me to do this is I don't
really know a lot about music and this
is kind of what they liked about it that
I don't really have a button on what's
going on with me with the music industry
although I do I know the Khaled's and
and and from afar and her and Halsey and
all these yeah all these artists I know
but I don't know like the ins and outs
of like who's throwing shade right yeah
whatever that means I don't know where
I'm from that I ain't got a new awning
on their camper totally different but
Missy Elliott who I grew up kind of
listening to she's gonna know similar
body type to a village yeah I feel I
feel like we're similar in shape so
she's gonna be there she's gonna be
there and
yeah there's a couple surprise guests
that I can't really mention that I'm
looking forward to meeting so crazy man
what a wild night that's gonna be my mom
just told me she's coming my father's
coming my in-laws are coming
I obviously my wife my whole family's
coming my kids I want to be my kids
there and get some photos with them and
all yeah be cool at the Prudential
Center where they're gonna have it so
yeah just elaborate even on a production
and of it just looking at this cuz you
know I know a lot about production and
putting on a show what they what they
have going into this as far as the
technology is just sick it's amazing and
this some is in New York right this is
New Jersey Prudential Center in New
Jersey oh is that where they usually
have her they usually have it last year
I think it was at Radio City they've had
at Radio City they've had it here and
that's the Staples Center they've had it
Madison Square Garden
Microsoft theater at the Forum Barclays
because I went to one cuz I would did em
TV show when I was young right and so we
went what was that 20 years ago the VMAs
yep 20 years ago so you went to the VMAs
went to the VMAs you got a ticket
somehow I don't even know right I get
out at the place I didn't know was gonna
be like I mean I've seen it on
television but I get out get dropped off
there Bono is walking on the red carpet
the same time I am I think everybody's
like excited for me right dude and
because I have no clue Bono is no clue I
never really listened to music I
listened to like um you know Alison
change you know I'd recognize them or
Guns and Roses maybe but um so people
are going nuts dude I have no idea go
into the place sitting I sat behind
Chris Farley's Brothers he had just died
and I sat behind his brothers sat next
to Susan Sarandon and Tim Robbins Wow
and in sync performed at some point in
the evening bro as long I'm Marie
urinating in the bathroom between Kid
Rock and Montel Williams Wow
you know that's a good person bringing
us together you know and I won't put
even I fell asleep in my seat proptosis
well I guess it was like a long night
and I just got kind of tired and I just
remember falling asleep